hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay
we just ignited a centrifuge to do what
I don't know but then again I've done a
lot of things that I don't know what the
purpose is so I won't question hi and
I'll hit him in the legs
gravity cricket
ah little ones another one
nope not today oh come on take that and
oh where to go and that and that
Oh so great I'm so great what's that ah
good but where's my flamethrower where's
the freaking Frank is my god where the
freaking freaking is my flamethrower
I had it you saw me I bought it or I had
it I moved it
Oh little things okay they're coming
they're coming
Oh where's the frickin back is it oh no
I sold it but but why did why do I have
to detonators not by
oh I did oh hi dad Nick oh so bad I'm so
bad at this game
okay and I'm actually gonna buy this one
cash money just to appease the haters
who hate that I got free stuff
well I did nothing I could do about
alright whatever
got to use one of my health packs do you
put reason all you useless dead oh not
useless oh that's not a detonator oh
whoops
nevermind then my bad oh I'm getting on
the tram yay
bring it on
fight him back he won't look at me
uh-huh perfect
yeah oh the bridge isn't the bridge
ripped up into a million pieces after
the asteroid Oh Oh anything but the
medical deck I'm surprised I didn't go
through Lutz
shut up lady I like le way better than I
like you not that I trust le I don't
trust anyone I definitely don't trust
Billy Oh No
she got bit by Billy Jim gonna become
infected with crazy cuz that's how it
spreads don't you know this looks bad
why do I hate the medical deck well just
go back and look at the video of me at
the medical deck back on back in Dead
Space 1 it's bad time Bad News Bears ah
where'd you come from
give me your hand and then take it back
hello give me that no you're not dead
take it in a face yeah make whatever
innuendo you want out of that hello
hello it's a different sort of
atmosphere and more like a techno rave
party who put the power notes back I'm
wondering where do people get the power
notes where's like the power node
depository cuz I know they can't be that
special I mean obviously they cost 10000
credits but I mean there must be like a
box of power nodes where can I hold all
these power knows someone's gotta have
that problem
know that funny
Oh blue it's gonna be oh that why can't
I hold all these power nodes give me
your arm
take it back I'm gonna wait shut off
steam yeah there we go and then I take
it back
Oh
are you
I'm sunk
right at this game
you see those sick moves that I did yeah
oh yeah everyone was my level of skill
oh oh so hard I'm so bad no come on
leave me alone
why can't you leave me alone ah what now
you got arms
give me that Boosh across the room
what how are you still alive oh it's a
new one ha give me that Everage what's
that
no give it up ooh yeah how's it hangin
Oh funny oh yeah oh ok anyway did all
that to just open up friggin door which
ammo I got not enough oh I had all this
torch ammo let me use it up I mean I've
got like 10 million units I used to
think that it ate up quickly but now
that I realized it stacks 250 of them
you know think of it better of it so
many people do recommend the flavor
orange it is aam be apocalyptic Ami's I
mean they're the Dead coming back to
life right even if it is in a different
form it's more of a Resident Evil zombie
because those are viruses and those
mutated people but either way flavor
usually
magic me
I wish I could talk to you I'm sorry
about everything bad things are
happening that's not the same dialogue
it is a different voice actor I'm
thinking from the first game
that what is here that's very different
what huh
I mean seriously I've got nothing
against you know that boy cut through
boy sector I mean someday I want to be a
voice actor myself I've got nothing
against him but I did liked the first
Natalie what's her name Nicole I didn't
enjoy the first Nicole better not just
because she was younger or anything like
that I understand that they made the new
Nicole probably older just to match
Isaac's age because Isaac was older and
the new Nicole the old Nicole looked
like she was I don't know fresh out of
college but either way I mean it could
AB girls go out with older guys all the
time but either way I like the voice
actor better that's what I'm saying not
that the one is now it's bad but it's
just like the other one better
oh maybe I just don't like her because
she's been whispering horrible things in
my ear the entire game that could be it
that could be something huh I got her I
said fire
oh there's no in there don't troll me Oh
did you see that wicked spin so Isaac is
Isaac's Pro
oh it's just oh yeah I remember this
that move faster before I just want to
say that right now kill its fire burn
baby burn keep me ah come on go down
there and get it wish spin yeah yeah
okay just popped out of nowhere well in
actuality it came over to the balcony
but that's kind of nowhere
oh the black one of those things fire
fire
ah not gonna give me alright thank you
burn [ __ ] Oh
come on okay maybe fire isn't a good
long-range weapons hey you're back
[ __ ] on there yeah that's more like it
okay oh hello oh really
I got no pity for you bro that was just
plain old stupid spin Oh bleep it's not
like you don't matter killer with fire
fire
yeah okay anyway Oh what what what
killed me what killed me well that was
stupid I didn't even see what the heck
killed me oh well I guess all with this
its baby yeah good yeah give me yo
oh my best I definitely need to mod this
thing's reload speed though in capacity
if I'm gonna be using longer oh what's
this
come on come on yeah hopper and then as
I got here well that did not work I did
not work at all
okay anyway now I'm gonna be mindful of
what is going on in Lucetta
oh thank you for that price yet it's
such a small creature okay now I don't
see anything down there
here I go there's that one it limits
fire
ah come on I'm gonna forget the
flamethrower until I upgrade it it's
crap until it gets upgraded it's crap
going back to the detonator that always
has served me well usually fruit maybe
I'm gonna go but later on I will get hot
baby baby dick ah
back at you I think it did yeah okay and
then it's even up all my time to see
stupid mistakes okay now
you go it's supposed to be a Blackfoot
there it is
okay could you leave pro oh ah oh no
that's why is this not killing you that
kills everything in like one shot that
took three Oh whatever whatever whatever
if I missed okay it's coming out of that
vent that vent is going to be locked up
I try so hard
boom you're not dead wow what where
another one
I swear those these things are the worst
nanny monsoon again I think of the
crappiest before okay that's obviously
what killed me before what let's see
here I see something pick it up maybe no
yes okay all right that's all the time I
got for this part thank you guys so much
for watching
I do appreciate everything in one of you
and I hope you're bearing with me when I
fail terribly either way thank you guys
so much for watching and as always well
see you in the next part bye-bye